Bandai-Namco is coming up with a really cool VR experience...
...that if you live in Tokyo, you will want to check out.
They're opening up "VR Zone Project I Can" on April 15th,...
...which is a virtual reality experience center designed for people to try out VR...
...without spending an arm and a leg on it.
The center will be located in Tokyo like I mentioned, and of course,...
...and will feature six different simulations including fear of heights,...
...where you rescue a cat that's stranded on a plank 650 feet above the ground...
...while you are also balancing on a plank in real life to help immerse you in the demo...
...and also scare you if you're afraid of heights.
There's also a horror game, a driving game, a skiing sim,...
...a train conductor sim and a Mech battling game.